اوكي انظروا الى الشظايا الصاروخ وقع هنا
ووصلت الرياح الى مركز البريد في الحي
هذا اقرب حي سكني لاحدى محطات توليد
الكهرباء وسط العاصمه كيا تضررت نوافذ
مركز البريد هنا جراه هجوم بطائرات مسيره
الروسيه استهدفت المحطه في ساعات صباح
الاولى سكان الحي عاشوا كابوسا دام لساعات
مباشره سمعت انفجارا ثاني
كيب ما زالوا تحت الصدمه
مبروك
اننا في الشتاء وباتاس بلا كهرباء ولا
تدفئه هؤلاء اشخاص عاديون وليس نازيين كما
يقول النظام الروسي
الماضيه بسبب الانقطاع المتكرر للتيار
الكهربائي ومعقد من وضعيهم اكثر هو صعوبه
العثور على مولدات كهربائيه كهذه من اجل
ضمان الحد الادنى من التدفئه وحفاظ اصحاب
المحلات على التجاره
اشتريت هذا المولد الكهربائي قبل شهر
عندما تجدد القصف للحصول على الكهرباء
ولاستمر في العمل
هذا الشاب مثل المراه من اصحاب المحلات في
كييف يفكر يوميا في توفير البنزين للمولد
الكهربائي حتى لا تتوقف تجارته بسبب
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
احيانا بامكانينا معرفه اوقات الانقطاعات
عبر الانترنت لكنها تحدث فجاه ايضا مثل
اليوم لا توجد كهرباء المروه سيسمع صوت
المولدات الكهربائيه في كل مكان مع هذا
تبقى هي الحل الوحيد للاكرانيين في هذا
البرد القارس الذي ضاعف من تعقيد حياته